as winter sets in conditions in the
musts of a displacement Camp go from bad
to worse Northern idlib is one of the
coldest regions in Syria rain is turning
unpaved paths to mud in this makeshift
Camp
inside Abu and om Muhammad are raising
their grandchildren
the wood burner is lit day and night and
she doesn't want her sick grandson to
get cold
I used to live in a wonderful house and
now I'm here in a tent water enters from
every side when it rains I'm older and
struggle to work it takes a lot of
effort the heaters the family uses
create heavy smoke inside the tents and
it's impossible to stay dry
a humanitarian organization helps in the
camp we receive a food basket every
month but it's only enough to last a
week or 10 days we then buy food on
credit from the stores
when trucks deliver important Aid to the
town of sarakib
a local Aid group The Syria response
coordinators say the supplies aren't
enough to meet the needs of about
two-thirds of the population of 1.8
million living in 1600 camps
the U.N security Council recently voted
unanimously to keep open a major border
crossing from Turkey to Syria's
rebel-held Northwest
it's something the Syrian regime does
not support but its Ally Russia does
surprising but important vote for the
council and those in need but volunteers
are overwhelmed and facing funding
shortfalls
sickness is spreading and education is
no longer a priority
many who thought their stay here would
be temporary are huddling in uninsulated
tents facing yet another winter loracan
Al Jazeera